hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round 5 of this
year's Tata still Challengers Edition it
is Thomas bertson versus Celine rubers
and it's uh it's quite a beautiful game
that's uh I I knew that as both of them
were uh pretty much natural attackers
that the game would be really wild uh I
did not expect it to be this wild so
both of them going into round five uh
have accumulated to two points uh a lean
by uh getting two draws one loss and
winning one game actually defeated Ervin
lamin and lost abhimanyu Mishra and
Thomas by drawing uh his four previous
games I think to uh to Audubon to
vaishali to soupy and to pay hatch and
this game well it's truly something else
let's dive straight into it features a
very cool line of the French uh yeah so
this is what happened Thomas with the
white pieces opens with E4 we have E6
bilingualing for the French defense D4
D5 and not Knight the C3 with Bishop to
B4 going for the vinegar variation and
uh
pretty much always you will see E5 here
it's a very rare that we will have this
position on the board and not see five
at least in top level chess but here we
have Bishop to D2 Thomas prepared uh
something special he probably knew that
uh she was going to play the French and
he wanted to play uh something else and
not the absolute main line and this is
like the sixth most popular move in this
position for white so okay the
characters on e4 uh we have Queen to G4
going after the G7 Pawn in just Knight
to F6 attacking the queen giving up the
G7 Pawn this is how you play this line
and uh she she shows that she knows it a
queen captures on G7 we have Rook to G8
Queen to H6 and now Queen captures on D4
uh White of course happily castles Queen
side now may be threatening some nasty
discoveries but Bishop back to f8 again
uh the main move uh attacking the queen
queen to H4 and now Rook the G4 black
getting a lot of development here with
uh Queen to H3 and now Queen captures
nft
and uh it's a fairly known position it
has been reached quite a few times some
maybe 10 games uh in in our top tier
tournaments have reached this position
and usually uh everyone not usually
everyone plays Bishop to E2 here but
Bishop to E3 is the strongest move
um that you play here for some reason uh
I guess everyone missed this or maybe
they analyze it on such a deep line that
I I don't have access to that maybe they
know Bishop T2 is better for some reason
but I will just show you for fun what
happens if if Bishop T2 is played in the
game it was it wasn't played but Bishop
T2 is very tricky it attacks The Rook
now Rook the H4 attacks the queen and
now look at this queen captures an H4
giving up the queen but only temporarily
Queen captures an H4 and now Pawn to G3
this is how you play it and now you trap
the black queen and um uh black of
course will have to give it back you're
gonna play a queen stage six Bishop
captures Bishop captures which check
King to B1 and then you try and play
this position
uh it's a very tricky but black should
be better if you counted the pawns the
black is up two pawns and if you count
the pieces of a black has two pieces for
a rook so black should definitely be
better here so uh why everyone plays
Bishop to E2 here is uh is a weird weird
thing but uh you know the the database
doesn't lie but okay uh Bishop to E3 is
what you should play here also was not
played in the game Bishop to E3 you kick
away the black queen and once the queen
moves now you play Bishop to E2 you
attack The Rook you force a trade here
captures captures and once the real
captures on G2 you will play Knight to
F4 and you will force The Rook back uh
yes you are down a couple of Pawns but
you have all the development uh you want
the black still has to develop pretty
much all of the pieces uh black should
be a little bit better here but I mean
you you played this voluntarily with
white but instead we have G3 here and
this is where things get incredibly
interesting she goes uh uh Queen to C5
here now prepares the the push E3 with
Bishop to G2 and now Pawn to E3
attacking Thomas's bishop and D2 Bishop
to E1 and now Knight the C6 uh we have
Knight G to E2 and here we have rooked
the C4 uh this is an incredible position
for black and there are many many uh
great moves for black here I will just
show you one line that is absolutely
spectacular because I know how much you
guys will enjoy it uh Ponte E5 now you
are threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries with the rook and a White's
best reply is Knight to D5 just
threatening to win the Knight with check
and after you trade here captures
captures and attack the black queen
queen to C4 and now you play Knight to
C3 luckily uh black doesn't have any
good discoveries with the bishop and the
White Queen so Bishop to E6 uh that's
the problem for white and now you pretty
much resign here uh what do you play uh
you uh her best is Bishop to F1 you
attack the black queen but just Queen a
B4 and now look at the look at the spawn
to A3 okay we can move the queen back
Queen to E7 but now once The Rook
finally moves or you give up The Rook
you can also try that but look at this
if Rook to D1 Queen captures an A3
absolutely crushing and now you might uh
think okay I know what's happening now
and now we're just gonna capture here
then we're gonna deliver a check somehow
with uh with the Rook for example Rook
to be for check and then we're going to
pick up the queen on H3 and yes you
would think that but no look at this B
captures an A3 Bishop captures an A3
with check King to B1 now Rook the B4
check uh thinking okay now we win back
the queen king the A1 only move for
white and now uh King day one only move
for white and now Bishop to beat you
with check King to B1 Bishop captures on
C3 another Discovery only move is now
King to C1 as the bishop covers the A2
square and now you're probably thinking
okay now we take back the queen but no
Bishop to A2 and now the white resigns
as Checkmate is unavoidable here you can
avoid but you have to suffer like severe
material loss like you have to play
Queen D7 check and after King to f8 you
are without any useful checks you have
to play Queen captures and F7 King
captures and Bishop to C for check just
to get some of the attackers away from
the white king now let's say Rogue
captures Bishop captures Rook captures
but you're just up two full pieces this
is of course unplayable
uh so just a a fun line that starts with
Pawn to E5 Eileen uh played Rook the C4
first and now puts pressure along the C
file and now we have Pawn to G4 now you
no longer have to worry about the E5
Pawn so much Ponte E5 it's still the
best move although it does not come with
an attack on the queen now Queen to F3
with Bishop to E7 defending the Knight
and F6 and now Pawn to G5 and now Bishop
to G4 uh going out uh going all out here
against the uh the White Queen we have
Queen to F1 and now look at this Knight
the D4 spectacular move violin uh trying
to give up the Knight and F6 but of
course you cannot capture this if you
capture an F6 then Knight captures an E2
with the check and there's nothing if
Knight captures then Rook captures on C2
uh but I mean that's your only move if
you don't do this you're just lost if
Queen captures then you capture the
queen but if you capture here then just
throw captures and see to checking we
want and now even Bishop captures I need
to attacking the queen and the rook and
you might think okay Queen F5 let's try
something like this but just Bishop
captures now Rook the C1 will be
Checkmate so you're not in time to
collect on E7 uh so uh you you cannot
start with uh G captures and F6 so King
to B1 by Thomas uh makes sense you wanna
get the king away from all the checks uh
but not Knight captures on E2 Knight
captures an E2 and The Rook captures on
C2 now putting pressure on the Knight
here so Bishop to F3 and now Bishop to
F5 threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and now we reach uh the
position from the thumbnail maybe I
don't know if I will use this one uh
Bishop to C6 check this is the only way
to survive you have to give up the
bishop in order to take the bishop and
C6 and here Queen captures and C6 must
be played but uh Eileen was a low on
time and she played B captures in C6 I
will just show why Queen captures and C6
is much stronger the problem is now
after Queen captures an F5 you're gonna
play Rook captures on E2 and now you
cannot play Queen capture or you
wouldn't play that anyway because the
bishop covers but what I mean is you
cannot move the queen away from the
defense of the C2 Pawn otherwise Quincy
to check followed by Queen to b2's
Checkmate so you're gonna capture on F6
now Queen captures and that's it white
uh has nothing here if Queen to D7 check
you're just gonna play Queen a king to
fate and uh there's no way to try
anything if Rook to G1 You're Gonna Play
Queen to B6 now threaten Checkmate and
if Bishop to C3 now you can play Rook to
d8 chase away the a White Queen for
example Queen F5 you can trade once
captures captures it's with checks so
you must capture and now Queen to G6
forces a trade and of course the
resulting end game is completely winning
for black you can see that black is up
like four pawns so uh Queen captures on
C6 here is a definite win but you played
B captures in C6 which also makes sense
as it opens up the B file for the other
Rook but now Queen captures on F 5. Rook
captures an E2 and now G captures an F6
and this is the problem the problem is
you cannot play Bishop to D6 if Bishop
to D6 look at this the queen covers the
seven Pawn cover z7 how are you stopping
this Rook G1 threatens Checkmate and the
only defense you have is uh well also
you can't play King to fade and just
Queen captures on H7 it's not much
better only defense you would have is
something like this but this is also I
mean just very ugly the queen will uh
gobble that up and other than that you
have nothing uh so yeah here you you
would just resign as black so that's why
you have to play Bishop captures on F6
and okay you don't mind playing this
because if Queen captures you still have
Queen to C to check Follow by Queen to
B2 Checkmate Rook to G1 now going after
Rook to G8 check so King the f8 and now
Bishop to C3 this is an excellent move
uh stops Queen to C2 in some lines also
protects the beat you upon but it allows
The Rook to B8 with tempo and Elaine
playing this with engine Precision Our
Queen captures and C3 is the threat of
course the the B Pawn is pinned so King
the A1 and now Rook the F2 again the
only winning move for a lean uh now you
have to defend the bishop and you make
room for your Pawn to be Advanced to E2
with Queen captures an E7 on H7 and now
it's a very tricky position only one a
winning move for a lean uh feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
this out while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this uh incredible defensive
idea and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show it is King the E7 yeah
but this is not what elim played I will
just show why it's very strong uh the
problem is now you don't have to worry
about any checks and if Queen th3 going
for D7 uh you don't care just Pawn to E2
and now there's a really nothing yeah
you can always hide an f8 and even if
Rook the D7 check you can still play
King to f8 and if Queen to H6 check now
King to E8 and now you don't care about
any that well you really don't care
about anything if Rook the G8 with check
you can always pick up the Rook on D7
and you always have to worry about the
uh your back back rank you will get
mated here and if Queen to H3 again now
you just play Rook to F1 check you trade
everything and you are completely
winning Rook capture spawn captures with
check Queen captors now you gobble up uh
the The Rook here and you are up a full
Rook so King the E7 was the way the
victory here but she played Ponte still
she was I think down to a minute on the
clock and after Pawn to E2 we have Queen
to G8 with check King to E7 but now
Queen captures and B8 and you have big
problems here yes you do have e captures
on D1 with Queen check uh Rook captures
on D1 but now look at this bishop to B4
will uh win the win the black queen so
what's up with that and also look at
this queen to d8 with the check followed
by Queen to D7 how do you stop both of
these threats well Aline finds a way she
plays Queen to D6 which seems like it's
giving up a queen but not really the
Rook cannot move from the back rank
otherwise you're gonna get checkmated
but still feel free to pause the video
and try to find a winning idea for
Thomas while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh it is Bishop
to B4 that's how you do it and yes a
black can block with C5 which is exactly
what she did but after Pawn to C5 Thomas
just played Bishop captures on C5 and he
was in this position on move 33 that
Ellen rubers resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so a
brilliant game by by uh Thomas bertson
who got into some very very tricky
positions he was objectively lost for
the for the entire game but you know
that's easily said when you have the
engine guiding you when you're playing
the actual game and you have to find
like 10 precise winning moves in a row
uh that's uh easier said than done so he
defended well and in the end he came out
on top now the problem is you either
give up your queen which also comes with
checks so you don't really uh have any
any tricks here you don't have time for
like pushing the pawn opening up this
diagonal and if you capture the bishop
then you get checkmated just Queen 38
with the checking the E6 and queen to
East D7 will be Checkmate as the the
bishop and pawn prevent the king from
escaping uh so yeah really nicely done
by by Thomas Bishop captures on C5 uh it
was an incredible game uh very nicely
played by both of them they've both had
a great tournament so far but in round
five Thomas was the the better player uh
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Dominic
pinteridge Suraj Kota Dominique Shirley
uh Jeffrey monster and Richard feyash
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata steel Challengers
and Masters until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day